how concerned are you about security or
maybe you just don't want to be
contacted by certain extended family
members like that one cousin you know
the one now for regular folks with a
thousand dollar iphone or an android
security and privacy are things we can
only help big corporations will afford
us it's the information age and
everything from what we eat to our
amazon shopping list is valuable data
well that won't be a problem anymore
with the seren lab solarin phone this 20
thousand dollar piece of fine machinery
is among the most expensive phones in
the world we say among because it's
nowhere close to the most expensive
which we'll reveal in just a bit but is
a twenty thousand dollar price tag
justified for the solarin that's the
question we're going to answer today the
20 thousand dollar solarin the first
thing that strikes you about the phone
is its uniquely curved screen it has
been forged from corning gorilla glass 4
so you don't have to ever worry about
dropping your phone in the toilet it has
been drop tested to astm and iec
standards so basically this is one tough
cookie the front camera is a wide angle
camera supported by a concealed
front-facing flash to illuminate video
calls if you're in poor lighting can't
imagine you'd forget to pay your
electricity bill if you had a 20 000
smartphone but maybe it comes in handy
when you're at the club the 5.5 inch
screen was tailor made for searin labs
and brings you a brilliant display with
16 led backlights that make sure the
colors don't blend but provide a rich
viewing experience it all sits in a
powerful metal matrix composite chassis
that is insanely durable the deco panels
on the sides are all swiss made and hand
crafted which really adds a touch of
class and a unique element to the
smartphone but it's not all form no
function the processor is a qualcomm
snapdragon 810 with two gigahertz
octocore 64-bit cpu to put it simply
it's faster more powerful and maximizes
connectivity the audio on the solar in
is probably the best in the market with
crystal clear sound up to 90 decibels
spl or sound pressure level
the bass boosted speakers will let you
enjoy the best of queen or post malone
without distorting the sound plus you
have 5 antennae and 24 lte bands
optimized for global coverage and
finally the back cover a beautifully
unique cover with a carbon leather
finish the price by the way isn't
necessarily capped at twenty thousand it
all depends on the hardware materials
used the device comes in a version
called sold out which is made with white
carbon leather with black dlc elements
and inlaid with black diamond all phones
contain a fingerprint scanner to ensure
security and a 24 megapixel camera with
laser autofocus and a four tone flash it
comes with a standard 128 gigabyte
storage which is pretty disappointing
for that amount i mean iphones provide
you 256 gigabytes easy so what's the
deal here well to be fair the phone is
more than just about storage or looks
that's in contrast to a phone like the
vertu signature cobra which cost a
whopping 360 thousand dollars but offers
pretty much the same features as an
iphone it has an internal storage of 64
gigs a 21 megapixel back camera and runs
on android what bumps up the price is
the design and of course the 439 rubies
and the snake's emerald eyes now the
solarin is the perfect marriage of form
and function the function being the
impeccable security it provides security
features if you take a closer look at
this back cover you'll see this it's a
security shield true to its name the
shield creates an isolated environment
making sure you have the highest level
of privacy possible when making calls
and sending messages using their secure
services how does it manage that since
android wouldn't be able to give you
half the protection this phone can
searin labs has partnered up with
different security companies and added a
new mode into the phone that encrypts
your conversations giving you more
layers of security basically it's the
hacker's dream phone their calling and
messaging service is fips
certified and gives you end-to-end
256-bit aes encryption so that's how you
get fully private communication only
accessible to the people that you want
to have access it also has a serin labs
made integrated solution for avoiding
detection and preventing any cyber
threats and all this is activated only
when the fingerprint sensor detects you
the owner so don't worry about the
storage you won't be using this phone
for keeping photos of your food above
the fingerprint sensor is a little
switch with a diamond in the center if
you press on it you enter your own
private system all the sensors on the
phone get disabled from the 3g to the
gprs turning it into a simple smartphone
kind of like an old school nokia so all
you do is make calls and send texts but
with military grade security you can
also send messages but only to a list of
people you have pre-approved for this so
you won't be getting calls or texts from
just anybody you flip the switch and
anybody who is not on the list gets the
dial tone the people on your list don't
necessarily need to have a solar and
phone their iphone or android device
will give them software encryption while
you still have your military grade
encryption does the most expensive phone
in the world give you the same level of
privacy the falcon supernova iphone 6
pink diamond edition is an unbelievable
48.5 million dollars and it's covered in
stunning 24 karat gold and decorated
with one massive pink diamond on the
back it's not the nicest looking phone
nor does it come close to the features
the solarin offers instead it's all
bells and whistles or a status symbol
for the ultra wealthy the solarwind
though exorbitantly expensive serves
more than status although let's be
honest if something ever went wrong with
your phone for that price you wouldn't
have to sit on hold with customer
service for a chunk of your day at that
point an actual human being would fly
down to repair whatever is wrong with
the phone that's your status right there
serenlab's first blockchain phone still
want a searin labs phone but 20 000 is
too much for you we don't blame you but
luckily sirin labs is working on a more
affordable model something around the
bracket of the iphone 10. now that the
brand is established siren labs has
announced their second smartphone fini
the world's first blockchain smartphone
according to searin labs the company
envisions a future where cryptocurrency
and blockchain technology become so
prevalent that they become part of the
very fabric of the technology industry
it works on shield os an operating
system based on android it is set to be
open source and is made to support
blockchain apps like crypto wallet
secure exchange access encrypted
communications and a p2p resource
sharing ecosystem but they aren't
exactly making the phone out of all the
money they made from the previous one
instead they're launching the device in
the blockchain universe with an initial
coin offering or ico meaning to get this
phone you have to invest in a crypto
coin and the device won't be available
until the company has made 50 million
dollars or more from the ico after that
the coin will be used as a means to
trade within the serum labs ecosystem
sound complicated well think of it like
this buying their coin srn or the serum
labs token gives you the right to
acquire serun products and services
meaning you'll need a certain number of
tokens before you have the right to buy
their products whether it's a 999 dollar
phone or the fini all-in-one pc they're
planning to unveil some day they're also
planning to show how people are longing
to disconnect from centralized banks and
services and they plan to provide other
phone manufacturers like apple the
ability to incorporate blockchain and
crypto into their devices in a secure
way bumps in the road it hasn't been all
fun and games for searin labs though
according to hog the solarin is the
top-selling phone at harrods and the
company has seen sales of just under 10
million dollars but that means they have
sold only 700 to 750 devices and by the
way that's 10 million in sales not
profits that's not quite the sort of
sales record a regular smartphone
company would be happy about still it
seems searin labs is optimistic about
the fini and it looks like they have big
plans for it too for example they will
be embedding a cold storage wallet that
is disconnected on both hardware and
software levels from the rest of the
phone the wallet will also have an
external power switch so any access to
your wallet is user initiated serin labs
history serum labs was founded in 2013
and it came together just to create the
most extravagant smartphone in the world
they made a phone that focused on
security and privacy the co-founder and
president mosha hog raised 25 million
dollars in seed money in 2013 then
another 72 million in 2016 and this
phone is either selling so well that the
company never needs to advertise or
their unique glitchy matrix style
website is enough to drive traffic
simply through word of mouth seren labs
market solarin to be an unhackable phone
and it runs on android now android isn't
exactly the most secure os on the market
so how does solarwind achieve that we'll
find out in a minute first let's unbox
this phone are you excited about the
finney what do you think about the
twenty thousand dollar solarin tell us
in the comments below if you enjoyed the
video be sure to hit the like button and
subscribe to the channel so you never
miss a video